Most organizations will have some type
of ticketing system, especially if they
have a lot of people that need support
from the information technology team.
These ticketing systems are useful
because they allow you to document all
of the issues that might be occurring.
You can assign any issues to individuals
in the organization. So network related
problems would be assigned to the
network team, server related problems to
the server team and so on. You can also
use this ticketing system to help
resolve problems. We'll talk in this
video about how to make that happen. And
if you'd like an overview of how your
organization is handling these issues
and how quickly they're able to resolve
these problems, you can create reports
based on the information stored in this
ticketing system. The help desk is
usually the group that manages and
maintains all of the tickets for anyone
who needs assistance with their
technology requirements. This will be
the group that will take the phone
calls, that will sift through all of the
emails, and might even take text
messages in order to understand where
problems might be occurring in your
organization. The help desk is then
responsible for triaging these issues.
So, they'll be able to determine which
issues have priority over others and
which ones can be handled by the help
desk and which issues should be handed
off to a different department. They'll
use their information about the
infrastructure and the resources
available to determine the best next
step to be able to resolve this issue.
They'll ultimately assign a ticket to
this problem and provide ongoing
monitoring to make sure that this issue
is handled in a timely form. There are
many different kinds of ticketing
systems out there, but they are all very
similar in the way they work, the
information that they are storing, and
the overall process that's used on any
particular ticketing system. In this
video, we'll take some common support
scenarios and we'll use a ticketing
system to understand how that might help
us.
The quantity and the quality of the
information that you're taking during
the initial ticket creation can have a
dramatic impact on how quickly you can
resolve these problems. The information
gathering phase happens right at the
beginning of the ticket creation
process. We need to understand exactly
which user is asking for this problem to
be resolved and what device this
particular issue may be associated with.
We then want a problem description and
ideally this will give us all of the
information necessary to understand what
the next steps might be. We'll then get
a description of the problem and we'll
try to determine what the best next
steps will be based on this description.
The ticket will then be assigned a
specific category. This problem may be
associated with a network configuration.
So we'll assign it into the networking
category. Or it may be someone who's
having a problem with the login process.
So we'll assign that to the login name
or authentication category. We'll also
assign a severity to this problem. If
this issue happens to affect many people
with a very critical role in the
organization, it might have a higher
priority than someone who needs
something that could be done over the
next 7 days. And many organizations will
have an escalation policy. So they'll be
able to determine if a particular
problem should be provided a higher
level severity than others. And based on
all of the information we're gathering,
we can understand if an escalation to a
higher severity is required for this
particular problem. One of the key
fundamentals with really any help desk
is making sure that all of this
communication is clear and concise.
You'll probably not be the only person
looking at this ticket. So you need to
make sure that you have a very good
description of the problem. You have
progress notes that you can reference
and add to as the problem is proceeding.
And you have resolution details at the
end so that anyone else who runs into
this problem can see exactly the process
you took and what the final resolution
was.
During the very first interaction as
this ticket is being created, it's
important to assign the ticket to the
correct user. And sometimes this is more
than one person. You could have one
person who's actually experiencing the
problem and another person who's calling
in on their behalf. It might be
important to clarify who the contact
person will be for this ticket so that
all of the people that are involved in
this process know exactly who they
should be communicating with. Often
you'll be pulling up a list of everyone
in the organization from a central view.
And very often this is integrated into
an existing name service. So, if your
organization is using Microsoft Active
Directory, all of the names in the help
desk will be integrated to exactly the
same names of all of your employees in
your Active Directory database.
Sometimes these names are added
automatically. If someone is sending in
a text message or an email, the contact
information is pulled from the email
address that's associated with the
message or the phone number that's
associated with the text message. And
although most help desks strive to make
sure that their list of employees is as
accurate as possible, there are times
when changes take place and perhaps the
database is not completely up to-date.
It's always a good idea to confirm with
the person calling about the issue that
you really do have the right name and
the right contact information to add to
the ticket.
I'm on the main screen of my ticketing
system. You can see a number of tickets
are open. You can see a summary of those
tickets, who's been reporting this
issue, and who the tickets have been
assigned to. This person is calling in
and saying that they're having problems
logging into the internet page. Their
username and their password is not
working properly. So, based on that
information, we can say that this is a
traditional service request and not some
type of system outage or post incident
review. Now, we need to define what type
of problem this is. We have a request
type field that has a number of
different types. We can fix an account
problem, get a guest Wi-Fi account,
there's a new mobile device option. For
this particular issue, we know when
speaking with the customer that their
problem is using the username and
password to be able to log in to the
internet page. So, we'll say that the
problem is associated with fixing an
account problem. We're going to then
specify who this request is for. And in
this particular case, this request is
for the person who's calling in. His
name is Daniel. So we'll type dan and it
fills in the rest and it has already
found that user's name in our database.
In the summary, we need to provide some
type of view that will tell us what this
ticket is about. And we can say that
it's problems logging into internet01,
which is the name of the internet
server. We also have a description box
that provides us with a great deal of
information that we can add into this
ticket. This is where we can put
specific details about this problem.
what information they saw. We can attach
different screenshots and we can add
additional details that will help the
recipient of the ticket be able to
troubleshoot this problem a little bit
better without having to contact the end
user. When we hit the create button, it
provides us with information that says
that we have created a new work item and
we can even view that item to confirm
that everything that we added into that
ticket is correct.
The information that we're gathering
during this initial ticket creation can
be important to understand the scope of
the issue. For example, we might want to
add device information. Is this problem
with a laptop or is this problem with an
external mouse? The resolution to this
problem will be very different depending
on what the device is. We've already
seen the description field in the ticket
and we can see that there is a lot of
room to put information into the ticket
itself. We want to provide as much
information as we can to make this
problem as clear and concise as
possible. We're probably going to assign
this ticket to someone else in the
organization. So, it' be nice to have
plenty of information in that
description field that they can read
through during their troubleshooting
process. It's usually in this
description field where we might put
recommendations on what the next steps
might be. There might be a note that we
need to call the user back for
additional information. Maybe we need to
associate this problem with a larger
event that might be occurring. Or
perhaps we're assigning this ticket to
another person in another department
who's better equipped to solve this
problem.
It's also important to add a category to
the ticket. This is a very broad
description of what this particular
issue is associated with. For example,
this could be a change request, and
change requests probably have their own
category. Or this might be someone
having a problem with their mouse, so
this might be a hardware request. Or
perhaps we received a ticket from HR
saying that they have hired a new
person, so this might be an onboarding
request. Each of these would have their
own category, and those categories might
be assigned to a specific individual in
the organization.
Each ticket is also assigned a severity.
This could be a low severity, a critical
severity, or perhaps a medium or high
that might be in the middle. The
decision on what the severity might be
could be based on a number of different
predefined criteria. If someone's
calling in with a hardware problem and
they're a member of a specific
department, they might have a critical
severity. But if the same problem is
reported by someone in a different
department, it might be a medium
severity. And often these tickets are
being handed off to someone else to take
care of. This is an escalation to a
different group. This might be someone
who is a specialist in this particular
problem or it may be a group of people
that handle these types of problems for
the organization. For example, if it's a
network problem, we can associate this
with the network team. If the issue is
related to a Linux server, then we can
escalate this problem to the Linux
administration team.
Back in our ticketing system, let's see
how these categories might help us.
There is a request type pull down here
and we can see that a number of
different categories are listed. For
example, we can have one that is a
generic get IT help category. Maybe we
are fixing an account problem. We just
created a ticket with that particular
category. Setting up a VPN to the
office, onboarding new employees and so
on. We can also use these categories for
filtering. So, if we want to see get a
guest Wi-Fi account, we can choose that
as our filter and we can list out all of
the tickets associated with that
category. In this case, we have one
requesting Wi-Fi access for a vendor.
You can see that this is a request that
came in via the portal. There's the
description, which is an on-site vendor
requires temporary guest access to Wi-Fi
for a visit next week. And then you have
details about the request type here.
There's the get guest Wi-Fi account. And
because this is something that is with
an important vendor who's coming in to
take care of a problem and they're going
to be here for a week and we only have a
short period of time to create this
ticket, it has been assigned a priority
of highest. And this ticket might even
have additional details that tell us
that this vendor is coming in to solve a
problem that's been occurring over a
long period of time. And since they are
visiting next week, this has been
assigned a priority of highest so that
this ticket will be addressed before the
vendor arrives.
With some tickets, there will be
multiple people who access this ticket,
take action on the problem that's
occurring, and continue with the
troubleshooting process over a number of
days or weeks. When that occurs, we need
to make sure that we have progress notes
that are constantly added to the ticket
so we know everything that was done
along the way and who happened to
perform those functions. For really
difficult problems, this can create a
lot of documentation to read through.
So, it's important that the progress
notes have important details included in
the notes, but you keep that information
concise that you're able to read through
relatively quickly. As new information
is found and other troubleshooting takes
place, we will add that information to
the existing progress notes for this
ticket. We often think that solving the
problem is the end of that particular
issue. But in reality, we still have
documentation to write up on what we did
to resolve the problem. This is because
we might run into this problem a year
from now and we might want to look
through our notes to understand what we
did to finally resolve the issue. Even
if this ticket is assigned to someone
else, they'll be able to look through
the problem resolution of an earlier
ticket to understand what you did to
solve the problem.
Here's an example of how documenting
this information across many different
people can help the overall
troubleshooting process. Let's look at a
problem that someone is having about
logging in to the VPN. This ticket
describes an issue where our team is
unable to log in to the Sydney VPN. That
certainly is a problem. So, this ticket
has been assigned the category of
reporting a system problem and it has
been assigned a priority of medium.
You'll also notice that in this ticket,
our ticketing system has provided
additional work items. There are other
tickets that were previously created
that are linked to this ticket. And if
we read through them, we can see there
is a duplicate. For example, someone
else has reported a VPN outage. So, this
may not be just this user who's having
this problem. You'll also notice there
is a ticket in here describing an
upgrade to the SydneyVPN, probably
because of all of the issues that people
are having connecting to the VPN. And if
we look at additional linked items, we
can see that all of this is related to
recurring Sydney VPN access errors in
the last 60 days. By compiling all of
these tickets and linking these
together, we can see a trend that has
occurred over the last 60 days of VPN
problems. And that trend justifies the
cost associated with the ongoing VPN
upgrade. All of these different
departments working together using the
single ticketing system can provide a
much more efficient and better
costeffective way of solving these very
problematic issues.